being on a team you want to be
supportive right your your job as a
teammate is to support your teammates
and that's kind of the biggest thing
people had issues with saying is you
know even if you don't agree you have to
be supportive and that's what teammates
do but I think back about you know all
those all those scandals like what about
um Lance Armstrong and the cycling teams
right do you think Lance Armstrong's
teammates were supposed to be supportive
of doping right so it's there's Comes A
Fine Lines yes you support your
teammates but if you see something
unjust and something wrong you can't be
quiet about it and that's I think that's
what was missing it's of course I
support my teammates I support them in
all things but if I see something unjust
I need to speak about it